quand je vois hier les élections
législatives et russe
six élections législatives partielles
c'est pas rien après dès l'entrée de
certains ministres au gouvernement
notamment et après les municipales
eh bien vous savez il n'ya aucun
candidat en marche
non seulement qui est en mesure de
gagner mais qui s'est qualifié au second
tour
donc on a une bérézina total des
marcheurs quel parti de monsieur macro
quand même aux municipales qui n'a
réussi à gagner aucune grande ville en
france il y as je crois 2 % des
conseillers municipaux français à peine
qui sont en marche quand je vois les
sondages pour les élections régionales
où dans quasiment aucune région en
marche ne franchit dépasse les 15% ou
les 10%
et quand je vois hier ces élections
législatives pour un parti qu'on dit
mort c'est pas mal puisque on va
conserver nos deux circonscriptions
donc il n'est pas mort fils jean léon
vraisemblablement en gagner une autre
dimanche prochain mais est-ce qu'on
rende bien entendu que le le républicain
l'est républicain incarne ce choix cette
alternative entre ce duel que certains
veulent installer entre monsieur macro
et madame le pen moi je ne me résous pas
à avoir à faire ce choix parce que c'est
un choix qui n'est pas positif qui n'est
pas bénéfique pour notre pays
les républicains se sont les héritiers
un parti gaulliste
ce sont les héritiers de nicolas sarkozy
de jacques chirac de charles de gaulle
et on va disparaître face à monsieur
macro qu'est ce qu'il a démontré
monsieur marc grosjean marche ça ne
représente rien parce que c'est un parti
qui est coupé des territoires qui n'a
pas de racines ces élus sont déconnectés
donc aucune alliance avec en marche
c'est ce que d'ailleurs nous avons
rappelé avait lors de notre dernière
réunion du comité stratégique il n'y
aura aucune alliance avec en marche pour
les élections régionales
nous le disons très clairement et ceux
qui seraient tentés par cette alliance
naturellement n'aurait pas le soutien de
notre famille politique
une vraie différence avec monsieur
macron elle est là
c'est sa lâcheté face au communautarisme
islamistes ça fait quatre ans trois ans
et demi qu'il est au pouvoir qui nous
annonce un texte pour combattre le
communautarisme menant le séparatisme
bref l'islamisme l'islamisme c'est notre
principale menace c'est manuel valls qui
le rappelait hier dans une interview
et il a raison c'est cette avancée qui
gangrène le monde mais qui gangrènent
aussi notre territoire qui s'accaparent
certains quartiers vous disais qu'il en
dise la mort neuf erreurs je vise
l'islamisme je vise le terreau de ce
terrorisme qui a emporté dans notre pays
plus de 250 de nos concitoyens qui a
fait plus de mille blessés
depuis ces attentats de charlie hebdo au
début de l'année 2015 le procès est en
cours
donc si on s'attaque pas à l'islam il
science attaque pas la radicalisation et
bien on va aller vers une société qui va
changer de visage
moi je souhaite que la france reste la
france je souhaite qu'on nous impose pas
des modes de vie qui ne sont pas les
nôtres
je ne souhaite pas qu'on nous impose par
la force qu'on impose aux femmes des
vêtements de soumission c'est ça la
reine parler du voile
je parle de ceux qui incarnent cette
soumission cette absence de liberté ce
terrorisme aussi qu'ils se confient tu
vois intellectuelle